former FBI director Jim call me exposed
today for being a liar a leaker and he's
always been a wimp but our next guest
knew Comey long before his days of
infamy he hired him as an assistant US
attorney for the Southern District of
New York back in 1987 joining me now
Rudy G New York City Mayor Thomas
personal attorney now we're gonna get
what you have a lot to get into but
what's your personal take away from this
report which is exceedingly detailed and
unlike the special counsels report
actually well written well I think this
report forget whether it's a crime or
not sort of details the worst director
of history FBI clearly in the history of
FBI take J Edgar Hoover put him aside
whatever he did this guy he broke every
rule I mean if you look at the Horowitz
report he broke every rule of the FBI
now I think he should be prosecuted if
you don't think you should be prosecuted
okay but for him to say I didn't leak
the report demonstrates that he leaked
he's completely lying today I didn't lie
the report demonstrates he lied
they just say they've given him a break
they're basically saying oh you know we
shouldn't prosecute not enough evidence
but he lied he leaked
he's a disreputable head of the FBI he's
a disgrace to the FBI he used it for
political purposes the report
demonstrates all that clapper was on CNN
tonight they didn't even ask him a
question about not one question I'm not
sure I believe he knows where he is
I mean I Brennan is the brains clapper
is an idiot well if you if you want me
to guess who orchestrated this clapper
is not capable of it
I won't tell you who I think did all
right Rudy here's what Comey said when
he was asked for the reason for briefing
Trump back in January of 2017 on that
phony June 2017 on the steel dust yeah
it was important for me to assure him we
were not personally investigating him
and I didn't want him thinking that I
was briefing him on this to sort of hang
it over him in some way I was briefing
him on it because we had been told by
the media it was about to launch we
don't want to be keeping that from him
and I was very keen not to leave him
with an impression that the bureau was
trying to do something to him
but today's IG report says something
totally different saying witness is
interviewed by the OIG Inspector General
also said that they discussed Trump's
potential responses to being told about
the salacious information including that
Trump might make statements about or
provide information of value to the
pending Russian interference
investigation Rudi is this evidence that
Comey and FBI officials were trying to
undermine troubled hundra's in the very
beginning that there was a conspiracy
inside that department to set him off so
at that first meeting number one it was
a clear entrapment 100% clear entrapment
by Comey who despite his moral problems
is a very smart guy unlike Muller who's
lacking in intellect this guy is very
smart he was trying to trap him like he
trapped Flynt just like it trying to
trap but you're not a target you're not
a target it's okay about I have to have
the thing in my bag but I can tell you
an island ityou horrible thing to do any
reputable prosecutor would be disgraced
by that so he was trying to trap the
president and it's completely
disingenuous for him to make these
statements now but who knows what the
liberal media is going to do with this
but this guy is completely disgraced in
the eyes of any FBI agent they realize
this is worse than than anything J Edgar
Hoover ever did when he walked in when
the president was the president-elect
and faced him with that he was trying to
tell him I have something on you so you
better keep me in office and he even
realized he was gonna do it there were
other statements that make it clear that
he realized he was going to extort the
President of the United States so I I
hope they prosecute him on the last one
what the guy should go to jail well what
this is a guy people should realize this
is the guy who put Martha Stewart in
jail on a lawyer went after Conrad black
on a ridiculous yeah in order to get the
Martha Stewart case was a joke I don't I
don't know Martha Stewart particularly
she's attacked President Trump now I
said at the time this is a publicity
stunt by hip hop over
that's what he did all right whose
conduct was more egregious and damaging
to the rule of law the integrity of the
rule of law equal justice under the law
Mike Flynn in a setup interview with
Sally Yates and her agents or what Jim
called me did for the last two years of
lying everything revealed today in
horowitz's report should be a like a
teaching manual for the FBI don't ever
do this again doesn't a line prosecutor
that just hired if J Edgar Hoover it was
up until now the worst director yeah
this guy has like gone way B he claimed
the thing that gets me Rudy as a
first-year associate at a law firm in DC
we knew basic rules of ethics as young
lawyers you go into the department as a
first-year prosecutor you you have spent
the week doing ethics review ethics you
know it he claims it wasn't a federal
record a sensitive federal record he
claims his memo to the file wasn't a
fail to record that doesn't pass the
straight-faced test does it know
everybody was alive everybody will think
I'm making this up but I'm disgusted at
Jim Comey I have been for over a year
this is disgraceful and because we have
this crazy anti-trump media they make
them you know Jay led down the path
garden path a disgraceful prosecutor
he's everything they've been against for
years the out-of-control prosecutor who
prostrates people for his own ambition
this guy is a disgrace left or right
he's a disgrace and he's very dangerous
but the noble goal that he and McKay's
known as a shock do anything you by any
means there anything you want it you can
lie you can cheat you can try to get man
afford to lie for the 13 times you put
them in solitary you bring them in you
get Weitzman was a total animal to go
after him perfectly okay now if it was a
terrorist they'd be going crazy Oh Rita
miss riots given but you know equal
rights where males to you and me equal
rights means everyone and includes Trump
and the terrorists unbelievable Rudy
thank you so much thank you great to see
you and I feel being a lawyer
I'm so glad of a lawyer get oh my god
drives me crazy literally you'd be fired
as a first
associate if you didn't know proper
document handling in a litigation a
civil litigation let alone being a
prosecutor and releasing information
during your tenure or after the mpi
absolutely I mean this is just like
basic and ethics 101 whether you're a
civil lawyer criminal lawyer or
prosecutor this kind of stuff is just in
CNN shame on you for not covering this
tonight I mean I know I know you're CNN
but come on James Earl Jones where does
he go to get his voiceover back